claudin blanchemaison merci soit d'être
avec nous avant de retourner à genève un
faire un détour voir l'aspect américain
le décryptage de ce discours de joe
biden vadimir poutine plutôt chaleureux
c'était une rencontre constructive pour
lui franche et directe constructive
précises concrètes
il a utilisé plusieurs adjectifs
peut-être on pourra l'utiliser un autre
très professionnelle c'est à dire qu'on
l'a identifié les sujets on était tout à
fait sans illusion sur les sujets qui
fâchent il fallait qu'on parlait pour
tracer les lignes rouges
et puis les sujets sur lesquels on peut
faire des progrès et il ya deux sujets
fondamentaux
évidemment le président russe comme le
président américain sont tout à fait
conscients de la responsabilité commune
sur la stabilité stratégique du monde et
là dessus on créé un groupe de travail à
très haut niveau pour voir dans les
trois mois
quels progrès peuvent être faits dans
cette voie on fait la même chose sur les
cyber-attaques qui est très important et
là dessus
dans le fond le président poutine a bien
montré qu'il était prêt à examiner avec
les spécialistes américains ces
spécialistes et les spécialistes
américains pour identifier les
responsabilités à chacune des
cyberattaques
plutôt que de s'envoyer des anathèmes à
la figure donc réunion très concrète et
qui a permis de faire des progrès
olivier d'auzan vladimir poutine ne
cherche pas une guerre froide avec les
états unis nous non plus a donc dit joe
biden
on sait que les relations étaient au
plus bas juste avant cette rencontre
entre la russie et les etats unis est ce
que clairement ce soir une étape plutôt
positive a été franchi oui tout à fait
je pense que là si les rencontres a été
à peser il n'était pas du tout question
de tension comme le prédisaient les mais
les médias il ya quelques jours il ya
quelques heures
je pensais que lés la réunion à genève
devait démarrer dans les meilleurs
auspices car bayonne a fait un cadeau
qui est formidable il avait supprimé par
exemple les sanctions à l'encontre du du
gazoduc nord stream à tous qui est trés
important pour
pour relier pour lier à l'avenir le gaz
le gaz entre la russie et l'allemagne
donc ça veut dire que ce gazoduc
d'importance pour apprendre à exister
dans dc suis moi ça c'est une très bonne
nouvelle
une très bonne nouvelle relève garner
même diagnostic
on peut dire que cette rencontre en tout
cas en apparence est plutôt une réussite
avec un climat d'apaisement entre les
deux hommes et dieu sait que c'était
plutôt mal parti même tout au long de la
journée les informations que vous aviez
nous avions n'étaient pas vraiment
positive sur sur la teneur des
discussions futures tout des coups on
aurait dit que peyton allait adopter une
posture beaucoup plus sévère envers la
russie notamment concernant le canada ni
que l'administration d'alten a pris le
pouvoir qu'ils ont prorogé l eau traitée
new star c'était le début de la
coopération entre les deux puissances
et nous entrons maintenant dans une
deuxième étape qu'il plus la
cybersécurité c'est un processus par
étapes vers une coopération plus étroite
et j'espère que cela se développera au
cours des mois à venir
cependant encore beaucoup de chemin
avant d'atteindre une véritable
collaboration concernant par exemple
l'ukraine la biélorussie un club dont
maison l'ukraine la biélorussie on sait
que c'était évidemment l'un des points
d'achoppement l'un des sujets qui
fâchent de cette réunion là aussi de
l'apaisement de l'apaisement enfin dans
la mesure où le président le président
américain a compris que il le savait
mais ça lui a été vraiment préciser que
pour le kremlin
la solution en ukraine ne peut venir que
de l'application des accords de minsk
tous les accords de mise
rien que des accords de minsk en plus le
président poutine je crois à tracer une
ligne rouge très clair en disant il
n'est pas question pour la russie
d'accepter que l'ukraine rejoigne un
jour l'otan et ça c'est très important
je crois que c'était l'un des objets
aussi de cette réunion était que chacun
trace et les rouges
sachant que la transgression d'une de
ces lignes rouges entraînerait des
conséquences très sérieuses c'est à dire
c'est à dire un conflit et là cela cela
a été dit pour l'ukraine
le président banda elle va recevoir ces
20 ski le président ukrainien dans
quelques semaines à washington
et donc qu'il connaît maintenant les
limites les limites du possible il faut
appliquer misc c'est difficile
politiquement pour le président et d'un
ski parce que effectivement au parlement
à la radars
c'est très compliqué de faire accepter
l'autonomie de loin et d'honnête et
c'est encore plus difficile de faire
accepter des élections aient lieu sans
avoir recouvré le contrôle de la
frontière
mais peut-être que les solutions de
compromis sont possibles notamment en
faisant appel à l'ouest pour contrôler
la frontière
olivier dose on sort ce dossier
ukrainien comme le dit claude banque
maison des compromis sont possibles vous
l'avez senti comme ça également en
écoutant les deux dirigeants ce soir oui
tout à fait tout à fait mais je pense
que cette réunion avait cgt simplement
une prise de contact et d'ici quelques
mois il ralliera discussions seront plus
technique
ça sera entra dans le dur c'est vrai que
je pense maison en tant qu ancien
ambassadeur ça vous le savez mieux que
quiconque
on s'est traditionnellement que ce genre
de sommet à bilatéraux pose des jalons
mais on
on constate dans les mois qui viennent
dans les semaines qui viennent si oui ou
non il ya de vraies avancées les choses
se font plus tard n'est ce pas c'est ce
qu'on lit les deux présidents est le
président biden l'a dit nous ouvrirons
nos 3 sedan 3 2 ou 3 mois
quels progrès ont été accomplis dans six
mois ce qui peut réussir et ainsi de
suite
et je crois que j'en reviens à mon
qualificatif général c'était une réunion
très professionnelle ou les problèmes
avaient été identifiés
on ne parlait pas la langue de bois où
on disait les choses sans s'invectiver
et surtout en mettant en place des
procédures qui permettait de faire des
progrès en tout cas il ya eu un acte
concret tout de même c'est le retour
hors des ambassadeurs respectifs des
deux pays
sur place vous propose d'écouter
vladimir poutine à ce sujet concernant
le retour des ambassadeurs à leur place
habituelle de travail à moscou et à
washington
nous nous sommes convenus que cette
question est résolue et les ambassadeurs
seront de retour dans l'horreur
ambassadeurs respectifs demain ou après
demain c'est une question technique nous
nous sommes convenus également que le
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
et le département d'état américain ont
entamé des consultations sur l'ensemble
de notre interaction dans les relations
diplomatiques pour déblayer tous les
problèmes j'ai l'impression que les deux
parties vont essayer de trouver des
solutions
garner ça c'est vraiment un acte concret
on le rappelle
des ambassadeurs parce que on rappelle
jamais assez que pour le moment enfin
jusqu'à aujourd'hui il n'y avait plus
d'ambassadeur en russe aux états unis et
américain à moscou
c'était une discussion au ridicule
les deux puissances souhaitent vraiment
échanger à propos de nombreux problèmes
et un autre progresser sans doute l'iran
les états unis et la russie sont
d'accord pour dire que l'iran ne devrait
pas acquérir d'armes nucléaires donc
c'est une autre étape positive est
également la corée du nord où elle a
réussi à une certaine influence mais je
pense que le problème difficile sera
l'élargissement de le temps il ya eu des
promesses pour à l'intégration de l'otan
à l'ukraine et à la géorgie
mais le simple fait d'évoquer le
problème est très positif il faut
réfléchir au sens général à ce qui est
bon pour l'union européenne pour sa
sécurité ce qui est bien pour les états
unis et la russie et développer de
nouveaux arrangements pour la sécurité
dans ces régions et une somme déjà pour
le moment haletant la première étape et
nous avons encore beaucoup de chemin à
parcourir
olivier dont le symbole de ce
rapatriement si j'ose dire des
ambassadeurs ça dit beaucoup sur la
tonalité des relations futures entre les
deux pays
bien sûr c'est un préalable
je crois que je crois que quand on veut
discuter avec avec le pays c'est très
important d'avoir les représentants de
chacun ça c'était bien ce qu'on pourra
noter que c'est que les ambassadeurs
arrive dès demain donc ça ça veut dire
que c'était prévu dès le départ que au
niveau logistique des les ambassadeurs
vont pouvoir travailler tout de suite
pourtant on a senti
arrêtez moi si je me trompe une forme
quand même de respect ce soir entre joe
biden et vladimir poutine plus tôt
il a tendu un adapter la formation
proche considéré que trempette et gentil
avec la russie avec poutine qui a une
image très négative
les états unis étaient considérés comme
trop et de ce fait n'a pas pu développer
des politiques avec la russie car elle
ne considérait pas comme assez sévères
joe biden arrivent en disant c'est un
adversaire qui en vaut la peine donc il
respecte son rival et à travers ce
respect on peut comparer davantage à
battre davantage de problèmes de travail
et à barack obama a eu le même problème
car on l'a entendue lors d'une
conversation alors qu' il n'était pas
censé s'exprimer publiquement
et bien des journalistes ont capté ces
propos et qui disons qu'il voulait
travailler derrière le système on semble
trop laxiste avec la russie on n'arrive
pas à ses fins notamment club danse
raison on imagine que pour le président
russe a tout de même été une forme de
soulagement d'entendre joe biden traiter
la russie de deux voilà deux
superpuissances de grande puissance
alors que on se souvient que le
prédécesseur avant au trump
obama lui par les deux puissances
régionales ce que ce qui n'était pas au
bout du président russe 1 tout à fait et
joe biden a bien reconnu que les deux
pays avaient la co responsabilité de la
stabilité stratégique mondial qu'il leur
appartenait parce que c'est eux qui
avaient le plus de givre nucléaire le
plus de fusée balistique et les instants
les armes les plus modernes et bien
c'était eux qui leur revenait
d'être responsables de la stabilité de
la stabilité stratégique mondial en
faisant cela d'ailleurs ils en font
c'est un petit peu un coin entre la
russie et la chine
parce que la chine est le rival
stratégique systémique de deux états
unis ce qui n'est pas le cas de la
russie et la russie est un partenaire
pour établir la stabilité stratégique
dans le monde et je crois que c'était
aussi un des objets de cette rencontre
c'est on ne sait pas ce qui s'est dit
sur la chine entre les deux présidents
peut-être rien du tout d'ailleurs
mais le président poutine est tout à
fait conscient des limites de ce
rapprochement avec la chine est tout à
fait conscient du fait qu'il a aussi
intérêt à parler aux états unis à parler
à l'europe de façon à maintenir un
équilibre alors que l'on voit air force
one son deuxième plan de boeing 747 400
du du président américain qui va
s'envoler dans quelques instants du
tarmac de genève afin donc de cette
première ce premier voyage en europe 1
ce premier jet set pour joe biden cette
première rencontre bilatérale avec
vladimir poutine
le gartner on parlait de des relations
entre le président russe et les
différents présidents américains parce
qu'il y en a eu plusieurs et
effectivement la tenue de ce sommet
illustre en elle-même le fait que la
russie soit une puissance importante aux
yeux des etats-unis n'est ce pas le bro
tolosa qu'américaines à la fin de la
guerre froide nous nous croyons devenu
le seul pôle de puissance du monde que
nous pouvions intervenir en irak en
afghanistan et cetera les etats unis ont
commencé à repenser leurs relations avec
le reste du monde
à reconnaître que la russie joue un rôle
important que les états unis et la
russie doivent résoudre des conflits en
commun j'ai parlé de l'iran de la corée
du nord et bien sûr le grand problème
sera à l'ukraine et la crimée mais c'est
effectivement un nouveau pas en avant
qui peut mener vers davantage de
collaboration afin de forger un nouveau
sens de sécurité de paix dans le monde
olivier doses ont essayé ce consultant
en relations internationales vous êtes
également toujours avec nous pour nous
décrypter en ces différentes conférences
de presse et cette rencontre entre
vladimir poutine et joe biden joe biden
qui disait tout à l'heure
voilà qui confiait ce sentiment qu'avait
en tout cas supposé un cave et vladimir
poutine que les états unis cherchaient à
abc parfois la russie est ce qu'il y a
de cela
sincèrement dans les faits oui oui alors
moi j'ai regardé le discours et la
méthodologie qui concerne l otan et il
ya qu'il ya quelques mois il ya quelques
mois la russie était considéré comme un
grand à un cas un grand sapin maintenant
maintenant je pense que c'est plus le
cas et que l'otan l'otan va pouvoir
penser à une stratégie qui va qui va
lutter contre la contre la chine et
c'est vrai que l'ambassadeur claude
blanchemaison avait raison le sujet de
le sujet important c'est bien la chine
or on sait pas ce qui a été dit ici et
même ça a été abordée c'est vrai que
c'est un cétacé d'un sujet qui va tram
et qui va qui va structurer la
géopolitique actuelle et future
c'est vrai que dans une maison que la
chine on n'en a pas parlé officiellement
ce soir ni dans la bouche de joe biden
de vladimir poutine peut-être que pékin
a été sur toutes les lèvres de cette
rencontre en coulisses en tout cas les
ied jean ping ont dû pour donner en
effet car on en a sans doute pas parler
ouvertement
mais elle était elle était implicitement
là puisque c'est en effet le vrai sujet
et c'est le sujet d'ailleurs sur lequel
on quitterait beaucoup de journaux
anglo-saxons à la suite du sommet de
l'otan comme ça vient d'être catho
d'être dit à l'instant la chine
or le gardeur la nouvelle obsession
enfin la nouvelle pas vraiment meilleur
l'obsession en tout cas américaine
c'est bien ça certainement le vrai
concurrent le vrai rival des états unis
c'est tout à fait correct
la chine est en des termes militaires
est évoqué comme rival militaire
c'est-à-dire son égal et les craintes
d'une alliance entre la chine et la
russie est l'un des moteurs de ce
rapprochement
l'objectif est non pas d'essayer ou
d'écarter la russie et la chine nous
plutôt de retourner la chine contre la
russie vice versa mais en tout cas de
les écarter pour éviter qu'une forme une
alliance leblanc faisons ensemble des
petits matelots réciproque parce que la
conférence de presse suivant de joe
biden
joe biden voilà à la cité des
comparaisons ridicule de la part de
venir poutine sur les droits de l'homme
on se renvoie un petit peu là la base
c'est de bonne guerre
oui cette manière et vladimir poutine a
contre attaqué en effet vladimir poutine
a contre attaqué en parlant de
guantanamo des prisons de la cia y est
et puis des gens qui aussi se faisait
tuer
dans les écoles dans les églises dans
les rues de certains de certaines villes
des états unis
donc il a contre attaqué mais en faisant
cela
d'une certaine manière il a dit les
droits de l'homme ok parlons-en les
torts sont bien partagées y avait
problème chez vous il ya des problèmes
chez nous par le gartner
effectivement l'objet en cette question
des droits de l'homme qui était
forcément attendu qui a donné lieu voilà
des petits tacles à on sent qu'on ne va
pas nécessairement s'accorder sur cette
question avec à son bord 200 restaurants
philosophie regarde par exemple les
conditions dans l'univers carcéral
aux états unis il y a trop de gens en
prison il ya ces mêmes problèmes en
russie en chine voudrait en fait que les
acteurs se rassemblent et imagine pas
sans l'autre comment améliorer les lois
comment mieux traiter les gens une bonne
gouvernance devrait être clé 2 alors dur
on pourrait commencer à gérer ce sujet
majeur
olivier deux ans dans la lignée des
droits de l'homme il ya eu évidemment
les leçons de morale sur alexeï navalni
le dossier n'a pas manqué d'être abordée
avec une mise en garde de joe biden et
une défense
devenir poutine oui cette question cette
question d'importance mais je pense
qu'elle n'intéresse plus le plus ces
occidentaux que l'école est russe et
s'est pas c'est pas la question des
droits de l'homme qu'on retiendra c'est
pas c'est pas dans ce cadre de cette
compte de cette conférence avec bye
donne et baï d'année et poutine la
question question des droits de l'homme
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas le plus
important c'est pas le nom mais satan
c'est le rôle de la chine qui a qui
mériterait d'être développés oui mais
pourtant joe biden s'est montré assez
voilà entre guillemets menaçant à la
question de savoir s'il arrivait quelque
chose l'excellent n'avait mis en prison
voilà ce serait lourd à payer car en
conséquence pour pour la russie donc aux
yeux manifestement du président
américain
cette question est d'importance mais je
crois que je crois que poutine a bien
répondu sur la question et que poutine
fera en sorte que la vanille ne ne meurt
pas en prison elle a encore d'autres
branches maison on affiche sa fermeté de
part et d'autre et on se renvoie la
balle ou un cyber attaque si bien créés
diminue crédibilité criminalité il y en
a de plus en plus de par le monde et je
crois que joe biden a tracé une ligne
rouge là encore en faisant savoir que si
certains centres stratégiques civil ou
militaire faisait l'objet d'une attaque
cyber il y aurait des mesures de
rétorsion avec la technologie la plus
moderne dans les états unis peuvent
disposer de certains pays le font déjà
d'ailleurs et je crois que la france le
fait quand ça lui arrive deuxièmement
cybercriminels criminalité à ce moment
là bien entendu lorsqu'il ya des groupes
privés qui demandent des rançons en
faisant des ataxies vert en bloquant un
système informatique
évidemment il serait tout à fait logique
que les pays se mettent ensemble pour
traquer les cyber criminels
et peut-être pour en effet les empêcher
de nuire et les arrêter et là dessus je
crois que c'est l'objet de 3e toi c'est
la proposition qui a été faite
un groupe de travail pour précisément
voir dans quelle mesure on pourrait
analyser les responsabilités et mettre
en place un dispositif qui permettrait
de traquer les cyber criminels
merci claude blanche les en remercier de
nous avoir sorti accompagné pour cette
heure de décryptage après ces deux
conférences de presse merci également à
olivier doses ont essayé ce consultant
en relations internationales et merci
également à rolle garner professeur de
politique internationale à l'université
américaine de paris on